tanto ong salvadoreñas como la
procuraduría han recibido más de 1500
denuncias de atropellos por parte de las
autoridades y muchas de ellas son por
detenciones arbitrarias que otros
delitos se han registrado
valentina es importante señalar que un
periodo de un poco más de dos meses y
desde que inició la implementación de
este régimen de sección se han detenido
a 38 mil personas y en la mayoría de los
casos se trata de detenciones
arbitrarias que no cuentan con órdenes y
aprehensión o situaciones en flagrancia
pero además han visto internacional a
través de la investigación que hemos
hecho también hemos documentado casos de
violaciones han debido proceso a la
presunción de inocencia a la defensa
adecuada en procedimientos judiciales
hemos por ejemplo verificado que las
audiencias que se dan de estas personas
detenidas que se presentan ante la
autoridad judicial son audiencias
sumarias de entre 300 y 500 personas con
un par de defensores públicos que no
conocen ni siquiera de los casos además
hemos recibido informes de tortura y
malos tratos sobre todo en la detención
de menores de edad de niños niñas y
adolescentes que han sido detenidas en
el contexto del régimen de excepción y
pues las 23 personas que se conocen que
por lo menos han muerto bajo custodia de
las autoridades
ninguna explicación ni siquiera que
hayan informado directamente a sus
familiares erika ya lo estábamos
diciendo todo esto ha ocurrido en medio
del régimen de excepción que tanto
tiempo más puede continuar esta medida
bueno el régimen de excepción que se
instaura el 27 de marzo de 2022 ha sido
extendido en dos ocasiones por la
asamblea legislativa después de que el
presidente muy que le haya solicitado la
extensión y la prolongación de este
régimen que es a todas luces violatorio
de los derechos humanos por la
suspensión de garantías que bajo las
normas internacionales nunca deberían de
ser suspendidas lamentablemente y a
pesar de múltiples recursos que han
impuesto las organizaciones de derechos
humanos por la inconstitucionalidad del
régimen pero además porque las propias
extensiones están también
violentando verdad los preceptos
constitucionales pues nos damos cuenta
que las autoridades al más alto nivel de
todos los poderes del estado están
colaborando en complicidad para
sacrificar los derechos humanos de miles
de personas bueno usted lo estaba
mencionando estas atribuciones que se ha
tomado el presidente y también las demás
autoridades entonces cuáles son las
entidades que pueden garantizar el
respeto a los derechos humanos en el
país
valentín estamos frente a situaciones a
un contexto generalizado de violaciones
a los derechos humanos violaciones que
podrían constituir delitos bajo el
derecho internacional hablamos de
detenciones arbitrarias de tortura y
malos tratos de posibles ejecuciones
extrajudiciales que se están dando y
efectivamente existen mecanismos
regionales e internacionales que
pudiesen conocer de estos hechos del
salvador al ser firmante y ratifica ante
el estatuto de roma se encuentra bajo la
competencia de la corte penal
internacional que en su momento podría
conocer de estas situaciones pero es por
eso que le hemos apelado al presidente
bucl que permite el ingreso de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos y otros órganos de protección de
naciones unidas para que puedan ingresar
a las cárceles que puedan monitorear la
situación estar en las audiencias
judiciales y que puedan tomar nota de
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos